I want to thank the organizers for
inviting me and also bring together
people from different backgrounds so I
can learn and talk and also thank for
Kira's Turner I guess will make my talk
much more accessible so still warm up
again and FTP is defined as a ratio of
force discoveries among other
discoveries you make so this is an
example so sorry is not very clear so
this is your estimator model so you make
300 discoveries so denominator is 300
but 300 are force so numerator is 200 so
since this FTP and FDA is the expected
value of FTP and if you want to contract
the are below self sake you 5 percent or
10 percent so qu should be quite nominal
level and it was proposed by Benjamin E
and Hochberg so this procedure actually
is the in addition to FDR they also
proposed a procedure for controlling
idea let P 1 to P n denote other and T
values and this procedure is very simple
first we order the p-value sorry B is
just make our should be the largest such
that at least that are of these P values
below Q times R over N who is the
nominal level and then pH reject order
our smallest of G values this is the
procedure here maybe say something
already over 4 million people here is a
measure of how extreme observation is if
you're not true
and in our setting you can imagine that
view observe why
following a normal distribution and the
you are testing whether the thing is
there or not if the choose crunches if
the MU is really zero we called a
p-value in our p-value otherwise we quit
a nominal fee value so this is our
setting here is a illustration of pH how
does it work graphically we first saw
the p-values from the smallest to the
largest so they are our church tisha
could a p-value you had that p-values
the other large and then which row is
ratios proportional to J the index and
the last will reject the p-values below
the cut-offs
here we reject from the right to the
left so it's a step up procedure so this
is the last rejection all the red ones
are declared significant they are our
discoveries so the BH procedure in the
original theorem they proved that if the
nulls are joined independent sonakshi
values are independent from each other
and the second as a whole that now
p-values are further independent of the
non loss then they can control via
probably euro queue and later Benjamin E
and the acutally they reduced relaxed
the independence the to independence
conditions by some sort of positive
dependence so this is path is with still
about so you see the conditions are very
stringent because it's really hard to
imagine that the real dependence are
party right and so arbitrary for real
problems most most likely they will
violate the conditions for FDR control
the impact of FDR and the beach is huge
perhaps the most popular error rate in
genomics two days ago the citation of
the original paper has reached almost
50,000 so every month they will receive
about 600 citations about the same of my
whole citations and certainly the impact
of fbi's beyond statistics and biology
in summer 2014 to the computer
scientists we can interest the yin FDR
there are things here and Lee and the
now Cynthia is at Harvard Lee is at
Google but four years ago they were
research scientist at the Microsoft
Research Silicon Valley and I spent a
wonderful summer they are working with
with the unfortunately their lab was
closed right after I finished my
internship they said story anyway
so what I was there three is to prove
FDR control of a widget does not have
anything to do with your work yeah it
has nothing to do with me yeah but it's
only we've had yes no potential to come
you only be that note towards so I was
there to prove FDR control of a version
of pH is it differential private beach
here differential privacy has nothing to
do with the rest of the talk so it was
challenging very simple because the more
easily barriers can be cannot be may not
be selected because our enemies we add a
noise to your p-values then you select
the noisy smallest of T values so that's
what makes it challenging because this
improves like martingale techniques of
story at all and the levant technique of
Benjamin and the yep Shelley they all
require a property to assess threshold
below it or rejections here does not
certify if you cannot work here as it's
a kind of hitter site as you will see
gcp cuts existing procedures does not do
not explore the robustness of the
procedure and actually this is the whole
point of the talk today so the theory
and the practice of FDR actually is a
right contradicting to me the theory is
very restricted only on the verb is
restrict conditions FDR can be
controlled at a reasonable level but in
practice the works so well people just
use it pre in practice I have done
simulations and really difficult to find
an correlation structure to violate a
via control extremely difficult so why
why there is such two contradicting
facts
so this chalk Viwa give us some evidence
why there is such big gap so the idea
conclusions right simple BH as a
procedure you want to argue that it's
robust and FDA is the notion of error is
also robust and the Viva shows three
points first
what's robust here here we still robust
is robust to dependence between nails
and the dependence between notes and the
non house does not matter too much and
the null distribution matters most in
FDR control and the last we were
proposed a new relaxed criterion called
earthly a consistency so first prat how
does robustness arise DC condition very
simple a procedure is called compliant
if any reject P values even the largest
majority values in below till times R
over N so this is by almost a definition
of [ __ ] right so the stretcher depends
on the rest depends on how many
discovers you make ah alright number of
discoveries essentially the number of
rejected appeal values however you see
in this definition you can skip some
small p-values does not necessary the
case that any P values below the
threshold must be rejected no you can
skip some of them actually this is a
special example of self-consistency
condition proposed by branches and and
rope rock we're here by definition you
see which is compliant and many variants
of [ __ ] actually also complained the
almost a very natural definition
the comprise actually immediately
implies some property on fdp fdp is
always bounded by this quantity so P
naught 1 2 P naught and there are all
the ordered now P values here and not
denotes the total number of now P values
and how to prove it
actually the brace simple first let's
denote V by the number of frost
discoveries then the largest rejected
now p value must be look like this right
because this is smallest the least
modest now P values there are at least V
of the rejected and then by complex
these P values must be below Q times R
over N so I must be lower bounded by
this number
so now FTP by definition V over R must
be smaller than that
so the weak here is must between 1 to M
naught so by the way we can be 0 right
you can be 0 than this definite this is
always non-negative and this is 0 so if
B is 0 just still satisfied so this is a
very simple effect
and here we can actually later Viva
consider a notion of FDR
we're the only panel penalized if you
make at least K frost discoveries the
original DVR is just the case of K
equals one in the previous kind of proof
you have seen that the non RP values
actually does not matter at all right so
meaning that actually the non-love you
can consider the nanos anniversary after
looking at the notes you can do whatever
and this quantity will always satisfied
so this means that the FDP actually is
intrinsically if they bound it's a
property of the now P values now how can
we make leverage the compliance plus
let's propose it a condition a little
bit redundant because this definition is
so simple we use iw and this says
instead of T inverse has to satisfy
satisfy I W and property if that novelty
values are joint independent that it
only concerning the knob T values allow
me use a fancy iawn abbreviation for
this property yes this is so trivial in
something okay so we have a theorem the
theorem saying that vocation be at least
the truth then FDR is bounded by a
constant time to kill nominal level for
any compound procedure so including the
beach of course if the P values are set
by set set by a table and property so of
course the pipe too many beach various
because compliant proceed conditions
very natural are the constants here like
C 2 C 3 C 10 can be given by some
formula as I will show you later and
they do a decrease it's ok large
decrease to almost 1 if K is really
large here the dependence between now
and the nanos can be adversary
by the definition of iawn does not say
anything about the nominal p-values so
maybe to experience why it is a robust
is robust to the dependence between
nodes and the normals so this is optimal
the cousin is optimal meaning that if
you choose a smaller constant say and
the queue is small enough and the M is
large dimension is large enough then
there must exist a complaint procedure
and the certain IW and P values such
that FDR k can be larger than stick you
now let's make connection to the
literature so the state about IPR
control requires positive dependence
between nas and the nanos and the this
is called PRDS our reveals is the
definition later because actually and
for arbitrary dependence you can show
that the FDR can be as large as
basically block and the dimension pans
cube so can be very large and in my last
last time I talked about this camera
point to me that a recent work of Jing
and Aditya
so they actually derives similar related
results on robot robot robot needs of
FDP plants basically they are saying you
had ship uniform FTP paths if you do you
can stop anywhere you want now let's
prove it very simple so first is a
compact implication of the compliance
condition and the things we assume that
the pivots are independent then we can
replace the knob p-value spicy ID
uniform order statistics so you want to
UM they're the other statistics of
uniform chip random variables robots
between 0 and a 1 so look like this ok
so essentially the original truth to
prove that this constant this quantity
is positive below by a constant only
depending on tape regardless of N
and this is actually haha very simple
you can show that this number actually
is a increasing number of and if you
make and larger to only increase the
proof you actually very simple so I was
stupid and so now essentially
essentially you let em to be infinity so
this is your constant and this constant
actually look like this
you see it's decreasing function K if K
is a very large kids very large then to
approach slowly approach one and you can
also consider a variance actually I
don't know people would really use it if
you penalty if you make at least the K
rejections this is nice actually you
know K you
you know art right so you know where
when to penalty for the original for
previous FDR okay you don't know when to
peel where to penalize because V is up
you in principle is unknown so here if K
is at least one then yeah I W and T
values the ending complaint procedure
work control up deep RK at this level
okay
so the proof actually is simular here
but it is a martingale so now let's do
some simulations and so here is a causal
means problem and we mix down the karez
matrix of the diagonal to be inactive
okay actually this is the most negative
can be otherwise it will be not be
positive definite so the nominal level
is 10 so
by the way so this is does not satisfy
PRDS your PID s require that so the
commence matrix in the off-diagonal
should it be positive and in principle
only applies to one side in test so here
I think we do a two-sided test this is
original FDR this is FDR - and we let's
the number of non-zeros m1 varying from
100 almost 1 to 500 and you see this is
the cutoff this is a nominal level 10%
they are basically always below the
nominal level so actually there are tons
of such such simulations use a
literature and also have done this and
it's really hard to violate FDR actually
at the our control and here now we can
see the kind of t-test
we observe right such 10 pair 10 such
vectors and we do a key test for each
hypothesis ult's similar here you see
the FD a-- will be decreasing this is
because the true not proportion is
decreasing if we increase the number of
track effects okay
and how they were always below the
nominal level
so now let's go to the second part and
so here what we have done so far is that
if we are happy to do say constant then
we contract yeah in this case so as
lines that between the north they are
independent and between north and the
non loss can be adversary and the war
and the between the in in fact wheezing
the nanos even can be arbitrary
anniversary in this case we control FDR
so it's robust to what robust to two
things the dependence between NASA and
the nanos robust to the inside with
independence of the non option value
let's review what what is Jia Jia's PRDS
essentially is the the conditions a
little bit complete it by roughly
speaking that if you increase one
component of X I then the rest of the
components of the vectors will also
increase and here I should be any now
p-value component and then using a very
live kind of live without proof by
painting Minnie and acutally the server
beautiful proof this day if the p-value
is such five key ideas then FDR's
bounded exactly at at Q naught Q level Q
so this is the FDR control world of PID
s here you see they only allow the
dependence weeding the node to the
archery and but between the visited
mouth to the be positive and between the
two paths should also be positive and
also this is what P idea says says so
and then now let's take a union and this
is a kind of watch the current probable
FDR control world here original and this
is what we did and of course they
overlap a little bit right so this is
our current FDR control world and now
can we make extensive GI control word
meaning that we make this deal leave
this arbitrary and
and leave now now and the non now
dependents to the arbitrary and relax
the independence condition to positive
condition can we do it so this is the
rest part of the talk
actually it's based on very simple
observation so this is the other
compliance condition and now let's
remove everything in the denominator the
denominator actually take this form well
maybe this one reminds me we must use
the science test actually what's the
distribution of this statistic Z of this
number if this if we can lower bound it
lower bound the dispersion of this
random variable essentially we can
derive a upper bound of FTP right and
this actually is very true sense test so
here let's propose a new condition
instead of P values are said to satisfy
positive regression dependence wheezing
mouse key at the end so here we replace
the last s by n if the null set by only
the null sets five charges
meaning that always enough I joined
three positive have positive dependents
regardless of the dependent dependence
between na Na's and the north
so this includes both tea ideas and the
iawn as special cases and no assumptions
regarding the non mouse and the PR DM we
can show that this random variable
actually stock has a larger than or
equal to uniform why actually this is
actually kind of is just a consequence
of the key ideas condition because why
if you restrict your pitch on the naki
values you will see that this is
actually if this is the probability that
this is smaller than Q it's just that
the FDP just FDR so by definition
charges on the collarbone - the contrast
yeah so this actually stop has a larger
than uniform the proof actually it's
very simple actually it's already
already yeah this connection to stance
because if this the test is smaller than
the nominal level then we reject
kolobanov this is what's the x does okay
so here's our theorem we are saying that
it was like a complaint procedure
applied to P at the end T values and
then after yet controlled at this ball
the proof actually is just several lines
first this is a compliance condition and
the second we make this random variable
larger replaced by the uniform okay this
is uniform between 0 and a walk then by
integration look like this so this is
nothing fancy
however this condition disc actually is
optimal is in some sense if killed
sufficient large sufficient small and M
is the vision large then we can find a
complaint procedure sorry this this is a
typo I should say that exists there
exists a complaint procedure applied to
starter PID on key values the FD a--
will be larger than that see it is in
essence optimal is it possible to get
rid of the lot factor it's a little bit
annoying and this actually is really
from the anniversary news if we are
high-paid to pound it at the restaurant
needs a little bit
meaning that you can't be a directory
but suppose you are masked meaning that
you can have only access to the people
so trippy values
faster - Morris - Wow okay so this is
that this case where you cannot perform
for Ronnie correction in this case
actually you will be fine
FDR it's bounded by three times Q so so
there's really a diverse way from
looking at the cenotes the p-values now
this is our current FPR control world
the basically allowed both paths to the
adversary and the B we didn't ask to be
independent positive correlated okay
so we kind of big Union and this is our
provable idea control world the last
part we were introduced in your notion a
relaxed notional FDR here our
observation that's look if we let killed
to be 0 this is what committed to zero
an independent of the dimension however
in the workplace in the in the in the
worse the dependence structure the level
is locked and times Q if you let kill to
be 0 it was your current tends to zero
but depends on the dimension it's not
uniform over the dimension here we
proposed a new notion of FD a-- actually
i want to stick your suggestion i'm not
sure whether it's really really
meaningful how our saying that's a
dependence of structure is serious index
tablet part by dimension is said to be
fer consistent if the FDR of any
compound procedure satisfied that FBI is
below F of you here at can be any
function as long as they were converge
to 0 uniformly over the dimension so
this is we call FD a-- consistency and
if the dependence of the north is party
there as we know it's consistent so we
have show show it it works depend
anniversary dependence of kill can be
as large as log n time skill then
certainly is not FDR consistent oh why
do the what's a motivation to propose
this relaxed notion it's because that if
we are happy with this relaxed notion we
don't need to bother with the non loss
at all the result saying that if then no
dependence structure is FDR consistent
then if you combine the none of the hope
depend structure will be automatically
FDR consistent so this means FDR
consistency actuated robot to at the
bursary knows and if this is really
meaningful to suggest us to focus on the
north let's prove it
actually a breath simple based on this
lammer FDR 0x is the FDR level if we
let's the compound post-procedure
restrict only the now P values and then
the support FDR
if you apply to the four P values will
be bounded by in this for the proof
actually very simple
first the comprised condition first and
then we know that the CDF of this random
variable in the denominator is bounded
by the FD a-- not of Q given by the
condition and the last fact then we can
use kind of integration by parts to
write down together at this slammer the
last step is to show that if act FX f of
X is convergent to 0 uniformly over n
then this the whole quantity were also
committed to 0 if cube tends to 0 so the
provide tree is also elementary so this
is our picture if we are interesting at
the ecosystem consistency to instead
there this world we only need to focus
on the dependence of the nodes that it
so far we can show that if the
dependence of the
not r+ we are happy but maybe they can
relax it so looks like a Fiat
consistency it is really a weak notion
but actually not always
I found a cutting example it's a problem
due to Williams of Jones and Tookie
so they are each they preserve
independent Gaussian means problems so
mu 1 to MU and n can be different so the
question should tested the pairwise
difference if mu is mu G and the MU J
are equal not so this problem so look
actually dependence is this is a very
independent problem because you randomly
set two edges of the graph actually end
up did not share any node right then
they are independent a recent paper of
bill at all sure that FDR actually is
controlled if at least one mean mu I is
significantly different from the the
other so the path means that if all the
me I are equals dancing under the global
now it's FBI consistency the case or not
actually my original goal was to prove
yes I try very hard to prove that is
really controls FDR in the weak says
however I failed and later as maybe I
thought that maybe it's the opposite so
actually I quickly can get the proof the
proof saying that under common law of
the problem of william jones and two key
the dependence structure of the global
now actually is not FDR consistent even
though most edges are independent it's a
almost independent structure however
isn't still not at the are consistent so
the in summary and here we won't just
argue that FDR and the beach are both
robots to adversary' dependence
especially between the nose and the nose
and a segment we show that the joint
distribution of the knots really
mattered most especially if we are
interested in FDR consistency after
control it's extremely hard and it was
really hard for you maybe actually we
can consider FDR consistency
as at the starting point so this is the
reference and the stacks pay attention
[Applause]
time for questions
about the constants right so how
important are the constants here might
be they long to let you go is it
actually one time to look you yeah it's
a few times lock of warmer kill right
yeah so this Q times lock one book you
actually if kids real support can be
large yeah if if Q is 1% the lock 100 is
basically fire right yeah like a
romantic comment maybe if we open the
book by brother fun then we'll see
statement like this that is under
dependence which is a business you're
talking FDR is control and in fact if
you look at the base and empirical Bayes
explanation of it is pretty clear from
the empirical base viewpoint then you
control FDR even if you have dependency
but the what Brad argues is that the
estimate of FTP is very bad it's
extremely volatile and so you may end up
with a procedure that yes controls the
FDR even under dependent but it's not
really useful because the MVP is like
all over the place if you see what I'm
saying like yeah a procedure that my
control D of your heart says reject
everything ten percent of the time zero
nothing
90% of the time that controls the FDR
but that's not a useful procedure and
that works under any form of dependence
so when we're looking so so so Brian's
point is that under dependence the
estimate of FTP is not great and so
that's why you see enormous variability
in your FTP and that says that maybe
control Utley of your is not good enough
and so when we think about extending the
Veniamin
to the dependent case how far along to
be one because it's there's a point at
which controlling the FDR is not
meaningful and so I've given any
thoughts about what kind of dependence
you know because you see what I'm saying
on here what time there are places you
do not want to go because I don't think
that the FDR is prettier an easy answer
yeah actually a correct with comments so
actually you can look at this term so
the annoying term actually that
existence is Q times Mach one mercury
why that's come from actually as you
said come from some events that fd-80
can be huge the most of time actually is
Q so this is a good suggestion maybe we
can further based our robot needs of FDR
control things if we only care about the
like con tile because the contribution
of Archaea from the tail event actually
can be huge here
is common so it's kind of funny also
under the positive immigration
dependents right that mean there are
certainly proves now and some guarantees
until under the negativity payments
seems to be a point of view but the
negative the payments should be less
adversarial to the whole story right
for example the variance would not
explode out a negative dependent so we
said there seems to be sort of
interesting views of this too that
actually make a different payment it may
be hard from a theory point of view
better it's not so adversarial to to get
concept to is that there's not make
sense yeah because actually actually
positive dependence is the region where
V watt reserved very large key values of
simultaneously or samokhvalov
simultaneously right and the pot
negative correlation actually makes them
even so actually this is a disastrous
idea FDR controversial it's the average
sense but it's really a I think as a
technical artifact and somehow so that's
what actually the big one out who
actually is really cute is really hard
to generalize beyond to the P ideas
and I think what Peter and I were saying
is that there is a place where a form of
dependence is going to really make tell
us that we don't want to use a view that
it's not a good measure
yes yeah this is what I know that if I
repeat that I care about these
experiment and you know it's either zero
what I have no way to tell really
yes so what do I do with the procedure
Alexis yeah and is there there could be
research on
but I didn't hear it hung up all the
comments over there so just to kind of
as broadly if FDR is not the right thing
to control the did you say there was an
obvious alternative or is this the
question what is the alternative if
there's some some odd dependence makes a
network yeah proposed various notions to
make it robust for example FDA existence
you basically control the probabilities
that your FTP is above some threshold
less five percent say five percent and
there you consider the tail probability
you are happy with the case where FDR
you got ultimately we are interesting
FTP so I have to be the random variable
FDI is only the expected value and here
maybe I think using the compressed
condition may give out assessed because
comprise gives an upper bound of the FTP
if we can control the tail probability
of the upper bound automatically be
controlled upper bound of the FDP
and so that's why I curate the compares
condition actually is really useful
alright that thing to speak again
[Music]
[Applause]